entre rage et désespoir entre
revendication est remise en cause qui
n'ont jamais été aussi nombreuses le
salon de l'agriculture
et cette année vous l'avez tous constaté
évidemment un lieu sous haute tension
est notre invité le sait mieux que
personne pour soir xavier beulin
président de la fnsea merci d'être avec
nous à ce rendez vous donc sur le salon
de public sénat avec l' agence
france-presse
vous répondrez comme chaque semaine aux
trois grandes questions de l'émission
première question on l'a vu on le voit
d'ailleurs encore au moment où nous
parlons marine le pen échappe depuis ce
matin ici a tout tué les a accueilli
avec une certaine bienveillance par le
monde agricole alors est ce que ça vous
a folle deuxième question quelques
heures après la fin des négociations
commerciales c'était c'était à minuit
l'heure du crime diront peut-être les
producteurs est ce qu'il y a toujours
cette victoire du du pot de fer c'est à
dire la grande distribution sur le pot
de terre vous le dirai tout à l'heure à
un chao de l' agence france-presse
et puis enfin troisième partie de
l'émission troisième partie de preuve
par trois eh bien ce sera accusé xavier
beulin défendez vous répondez à vos
détracteurs ils sont nombreux car on les
attend on les entend nombreux également
depuis le début du salon un de jean-luc
mélenchon à d'autres responsables
politiques et puis pivot rivaux
syndicaux également qui vous tiennent
vous comme premier responsable de ce qui
arrive aujourd'hui à l'agriculture
française à leur première question
xavier beulin parmi vos spécialités ici
pendant le salon c'est l'accueil des
personnalités politiques évidemment il
ya eu le chef de l'état de mayorat
nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui parmi les
responsables politiques marine le pen
vous êtes allés l'accueillir
non non et j'attends d'ailleurs qu'elles
viennent nous rendre visite sur le sens
de l'effet soit parce que c'est le lieu
on peut discuter
je dois dire qu'avec marine le pen les
relations sont pas simples d'abord parce
qu'elle m'accuse régulièrement sans
vraiment d'ailleurs se plonger sur les
questions de fond ce que je regrette
mais je vous accuse elle aussi alors oui
je peux aussi me tenir des propos
finalement qui vont dans le sens du poil
qui rassure qui je crois qu'aujourd'hui
endroit là on doit la vérité on la doit
aux éleveurs on la doit aux agriculteurs
on la doit aussi aux consommateurs et
aux citoyens
on est dans une situation très difficile
avec des marchés mondiaux qui sont quand
même plutôt bas avant d'entrer dans le
temps long mais ça va des dossiers il ya
quand même la question de marine le pen
vous me dites vous vous n'êtes pas allés
l'accueillir donc c'est un choix
délibéré de votre part vous dites mais
elle vient pas nous voir mais vous non
plus vous n'avez pas les payeurs et cela
il va accueillir les membres
d'abord de l'exécutif le chef de l'état
leroy ministre le ministre de la culture
ça va de soi bien sûr on n'a pas à
accueillir non plus toutes les
personnalités qui passe sur le salon
c'est nous qui aujourd'hui sommes en
situation de recevoir les personnalités
je dois d'ailleurs dire qu'à la fnsea on
a proposé onze questions à toutes les
personnalités politiques qui vont passer
et on leur demande de pouvoir répondre à
ces questions alors je le disais une
certaine bienveillance quand même hein
vous l'avez constaté vous allez sans
doute pouvoir le déplorer dans un
instant pour la présidente du front
national pour l'écouter elle a tenu ces
propos tout à l'heure lors de sa visite
aujourd'hui la situation est une
situation catastrophique on le dit
chaque année mais l'urgence est
maintenant les mesures qui auraient dû
être prises il ya deux ans ne l'ont ne
m'ont pas aidé prise aujourd'hui on
parle encore de négociations
on essaye de faire de cette crise un
problème franco français c'est pas un
problème franco français
il faut faire le bras de fer avec
bruxelles maintenant stop c'est terminé
moi je crois que pour sauver la peau des
éleveurs français
il faut avoir la peau de phil hogan le
commissaire européen à l'agriculture
c'est très clair parce que cet homme là
c'est l'homme qui défend toutes les
mesures qui sont en train de tuer
l'agriculture française alors marine le
pen fidèle à son discours haro sur
l'europe la pro du commissaire alors
qu'en pensez vous ça va très loin
comment est-ce que pensez vous de cette
demande de démission du commissaire au
rôle d'abord je suis heureux que man in
open parle d'europe c'est rare non l on
parle souvent non elle est souvent la
forme oui pour la faute ou pour sortir
de leur abri
là elle dit finalement les problèmes que
nous avons en france ils viennent de
l'europe
ce sur quoi je suis d'accord c'est vrai
en garde si grande si des problèmes
aujourd'hui embargo sur la démission de
fil au grain
non attendez enfin après bon moi ça me
regarde plus on a aujourd'hui des
institutions est-ce qu'on veut m
la cabane sur le chien comme on dit chez
moi est-ce qu'on veut aussi travailler
et faire progresser un certain nombre de
posture
moi ce que je demande aujourd'hui à phil
hogan ces deux choses d'abord qu'il
sorte de sa posture libéral mais ça sera
possible
peut-être que la solution c'est de
changer de commissaire a forcément
impossible c'est aussi à juncker de
faire le boulot
il ya un président mal comment détruire
renier ses pas de second et ne renie et
aussi tous nos séjours de l'europe
aujourd'hui shell grossiord il s'agit de
comprendre et d'accepter un fait qui est
que l'agriculture ne peut pas être
traité comme un autre secteur économique
parce qu'on travaillait que du vivant
on travaille des impondérables s'appelle
le climat qui s'appelle l'évolution sur
les marchés
ça ça doit être prise en compte or la
pac actuelle il est vrai ne répond plus
à ses situations de crise donc il faut
restaurer un certain nombre de
mécanismes mais par ailleurs il faut
aussi qu avec nos collègues européens
nous faisions convergence je demande
aussi au chiva aujourd'hui au chef de
l'état de bien prendre en compte la
situation des cols la france est la
première puissance agricole européenne
est ce que le chef de l'état aujourd'hui
a les moyens à la conviction de m au
même titre que le break site
peut-être même que la question des
réfugiés même si je suis prudent sur ce
sujet là la question agricole au même
niveau pour le dire autrement
est ce que la voix de la france
aujourd'hui peut être entendu c'est ça
notre sujet à partir de là je pense qu
avec madame merkel avec un ca tombe
d'autres dirigeants
la commission se mirent à quand même aux
demandes des états membres alors je vous
envoyons pas systématiquement toutes les
responsabilités à la commission bac si
les états membres ne sont pas convaincus
eux mêmes ne nous étonnons pas que là
d'accord donc de renvoyer la balle de 2
sur le gouvernement français c'est ce
qu'a fait également aujourd'hui bruno le
maire un qui était ministre de
l'agriculture qui connaît bien le
secteur et je vais d'ailleurs décidé de
passer trois jours pleins sur le salon
cette année
on l'écouté je vois un certain
parallélisme dans vos propos je pense
qu'il faut remettre en question la
politique agricole commune par la
direction qu'elle a choisi aujourd'hui
et je voudrais que la france en fasse
une priorité aussi importante que la
question des réfugiés aujourd'hui du
contrôle des frontières
est-ce que c'est l'avenir de nos paysans
qui est en jeu et je voudrais que la
france tape du poing sur la table
au niveau du président de la république
à qui j'ai écrit je lui demandé de le
faire
en rassemblant tous les chefs d'état et
en dix ans la direction actuelle de la
politique agricole commune nous emmène
tous dans le mur
parce que vous êtes en train de
supprimer tous les instruments
d'intervention tous les instruments de
régulation
vous êtes en train d'aller vers une
libéralisation totale qui va aboutir à
la fermeture de dizaines de milliers
d'exploitations en europe c'est à la
france de taper du poing sur la table
pour réclamer cette régulation et c'est
l'enjeu le plus important aujourd'hui
pour nos agriculteurs gagnent alors vous
avez quel est le discours c'est ce que
vous dites est un bras de fer
aujourd'hui bien sûr entre la france et
l'europe et que la france n'est que
faiblesse alors je rajoute quand même un
argument aux propos de bruno le maire
que je partage je le dis très clairement
quand je discute aujourd'hui avec les
dirigeants allemands qu'ils soient
politiques qu'ils soient syndicaux
j'entends à peu près la même réponse
laissons mourir les plus faibles et ça
fera de la place pour les autres ça
n'est pas acceptable
les plus faibles aujourd'hui ça voudrait
dire qu'en france on abandonne en
moyenne la tranche 25 40 ans les gens
qui viennent d'investir qui sont pleines
capacités de pouvoir produire et
d'assurer l'agriculture de demain c'est
pas acceptable comme propos donc quand
on évoque la régulation quand on évoque
la crise
oui il faut aujourd'hui des instruments
au niveau communautaire accord et dont
il faut peser à bruxelles mais j'ai
quand même sur l'accueil qu'a reçu ici
marine le pen est ce que ça vous a folle
puisque c'était la question de cette
première partie prendre part 3 s'est
passé de leurs infos les mais ce que je
veux quand même que mes collègues
comprennent c'est que on peut se
contenter comme ça d'un discours un peu
facile
un peu démago quand même disons le on
doit aussi analyser l'ensemble
l'ensemble des sujets et je note quand
même que pour beaucoup d'agriculteurs
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont très très
majoritaire chacun a conscience que si
l'agriculture française aujourd'hui est
arrivé à ce niveau de performance elle
le doit aussi à la construction
européenne
ce que nous avons à faire c'est beaucoup
plus que dénoncer
que de faire en sorte que les fissures
aujourd'hui qui pourrait apparaître dans
la construction européenne ne cesse de
s'élargir
moi je préfère travailler à la
convergence européenne qui a des formes
de divergences et surtout à défendre nos
positions
je voudrais dire d'ailleurs qu'à ce
propos la en particulier sur le plan
social sur un certain nombre de normes
environnementales
oui aujourd'hui il ya des distorsions
d'un pays à l'autre
qu'attendent les institutions
communautaires pour nous rapprocher des
meilleurs en sorte que ce marché unique
puisse bien quand vous voyez aujourd'hui
nos adhérents beaucoup de personnes du
monde agricole parce qu'il s'était passé
discours de la démagogie c'est celui de
marine le pen vous mais ils sont
différents ils sont à bout quand
aujourd'hui vous perdez 3 à 4000 euros
par semaine quand vous êtes producteur
de porcs ne vous étonnez pas que les
discours un peu facile puisse être
évidemment des discours de réassurance
est-ce que ça construit pour autant je
suis pas sûr moi je suis en train de me
battre en ce moment pour mettre sur pied
un fonds à destination des producteurs
de porcs payé par la grande distribution
qui aujourd'hui se fait quand même sans
jeu de mots beaucoup de gras sur le dos
des paysans se font on va le mettre en
place
roux c'est pas la panacée mais ça va
permettre pendant quelques mois de
ramener de la trésorerie de ramener un
peu de magie chaîne hbo et c'est du
concret je suis pas en train de faire de
l'entente et de l'incantation sur ces
sujets là d'accord à propos du ministre
de l'agriculture
il passe des mauvais quart d'heure ici
oui entièrement il est copieusement hué
il a été sifflé tout à l'heure aux
questions au gouvernement à l'assemblée
nationale
on peut poser la question des forces et
des faiblesses peut-être surtout de
votre ministre de l'agriculture je veux
faire peut-être une question à la marine
le pen est ce qu'il faut demander sa
démission quand on est dans votre genre
série centre du gabon et je suis
républicain je suis démocrate vient
gouvernement au travail avec les
ministres en poste
ce que je peux noter quand même c'est
que ya probablement celle mise en
culture une difficulté de forme en
particulier à il est à dire mais il est
porte parole du gouvernement
il prend la parole huit fois sur dix
pour parler de tas de sujets qui n'ont
rien à voir une agriculture
l'agriculteur lui en face derrière son
écran derrière son son poste de radio il
en emploi il entend son ministre parler
de tas de sujets ne pas parler
d'agriculture
donc il faut bien comprendre que ça
forcément ça est forcément des impacts
peut-être que l'erreur du présent dans
le public ça a été de confirmer dans ce
rôle de porte parole
peut-être aurait-il fallu qu d'hésiter
définitivement on le nomme ministre de
l'agriculture
bah c'est votre souhait votre corps
votre revendication là que nous avons
une vocation parce qu on lui enlevait
une casquette
d'abord on a besoin d'un ministre à
plein-temps accord on a besoin d'un
ministre qui soit mieux et plus présents
à bruxelles
il l'est depuis quelques semaines parce
que ça chauffe peut-être insuffisamment
auparavant je lui dis aussi attention il
suffit pas d'aller à bruxelles
il faut faire aujourd'hui alliance est
recherché et les majorités au sein des
états membres pour porter aussi nos
valeurs beau dit il suffit pas d'elle à
bruxelles on lui a fait le procès
également à stéphane le foll donne pas
elle est suffisamment au conseil
européen à l'agriculture
oui ça c'est sûr de lui adresser vous
aussi on sera d'ailleurs j'ignorais ce
cependant les ans je l'ignorais non
vraiment je suis sincère mais mais le
concéder mis sur une chose la
construction d'une pensée d'une au fond
d'une réaction est au niveau de la crise
européenne c'en est une autre
et ça ça se construit je fais en ce
moment même mois la tournée des
capitales pour aller voir mes collègues
mes homologues et leur dire voilà est-ce
qu'on peut se mettre d'accord sur une
feuille de route
comment est-ce qu'on régule demain en
laye en port quel type de mesures de
gestion prises on peut mettre en place
ça se construit tout ça on peut pas une
fois par mois est à bruxelles et dire
voilà ce que je pense voilà ce qu'il
faudrait
non il faut construire vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que vous réclamez un
ministre à temps plein en quelque sorte
vous avez l'occasion de dire directement
au chef de l'état lors de la libération
on sait que ce qu'est ce qui vous a
répondu on est reçu en est on discute et
on évitera au chef de l'état il vous
entend et il prend ses responsabilités
moi je discutais commis sur la culture
je discute aussi commises l'économie des
finances je discute avec les miches
travail parce qu'on a des sujets qui
nous sont évidemment très propre en
matière à l'école on a beaucoup de
saisonniers en agriculture on les traite
pas forcément bien dans les différents
projets de loi la loi sur la pénibilité
par exemple la loi sur la pop les
mantais ressentent et surtout ça
l'agriculture est mal servi donc voilà
on fait aussi
l'accueil travail de responsable
professionnel il sentait un peu délaissé
d'une certaine manière si je comprends
bien tout cas bon aujourd'hui je peux au
moins dire et ça ne frustre à panis
parce que lui-même l'a reconnu
je pense qu'il a sous-estimé la
profondeur et la gravité de la crise
c'est seulement depuis un passé assez
récent qu'on a vraiment pris en compte
la dimension qui étaient devant nous je
rappelle que à ce même salon à ce même
plateau il ya un an
reprenez mes propos j'alertais déjà sur
un début de crise qui était sérieux un
an après ça c'est plutôt à planquer
découle en partie on l'a dit que c'est
un certain nombre de décisions de
l'union européenne
oui ont mal été géré notamment la fin
des quotas laitiers mais aussi parce que
enfin disons les choses simplement mais
en même temps très directement comment
se fait-il qu'un certain nombre de pays
aujourd'hui ne vivent pas la crise de la
même manière que nous la vivons ici
simplement parce que nous avons des
niveaux de compétitivité en france
oui qui n'ont plus rien à voir ça c'est
notre faute ça c'est notre
responsabilité pour ça que j'ai salué la
semaine dernière une des annonces du
premier ministre qui va être une baisse
de charges sociales ce soit pour avait
obtenu et pour tout les admire les
alliances de matignon que vous voulez
positive positive et oui président
d'avec une interview il faut quand même
il faut reconnaître quand même ce qui
est fait 1 on va écouter le premier
ministre parce qu'il a été interrogé
lors de sa visite samedi et on lui a
demandé
si les agriculteurs lui faisait encore
confiance face à toutes ces crises qui
s'accumulent
ils savent que à notre niveau nous
agissons déjà mais qu'il faut d'abord
que les professionnels sera organise que
les filières se réorganise
il faut agir aussi au niveau de l'europe
on nous a aussi beaucoup parlé des
négociations commerciales entre l'union
européenne et les etats unis
non je pense que cette confiance doit
continuer ils savent de toute façon que
ya pas de solution facile et toutes
faites et que les messages de démagogie
ne peuvent pas passer non plus voilà
donc le premier ministre y est restée au
sol ont voulu fait toujours confiance
la confiance elle se gagne aussi par les
décisions et surtout par le respect des
décisions prises
ce que j'attends c'est que tout ce qui a
été annoncé depuis deux semaines se
mettent en oeuvre très très vite donc il
ya des décrets apprendre par exemple sur
la baisse des charges
il ya des décrets à prendre sur les
normes et sur la réglementation que nous
attendons si tout ça vient en temps
utile oui alors nous pourrons dire que
il ya une relative confiance aujourd'hui
alors avec l'exécutif
vous rajoutez un propos qu'a tenus le
poids est ministre il dit il faut aussi
travailler sur les filières et il a
raison là dessus on a besoin aussi de se
restructurer de renforcer le rôle de nos
filières mais ça suppose aussi qu'on
n'est pas un double discours en france
la chance de l'agriculture française
c'est sa diversité
or qu'est ce qui se passe depuis des
années on oppose les uns et les autres
on oppose une certaine organisation qui
permet de répondre un sens très
concurrentiel quel sens mondiale on nous
a bercés aujourd'hui on nous a bercés
par don à travers les négociations
commerciales depuis des années dans une
grande cour mondiale sur laquelle il
faut quand même donner des coudes et
jouer des coudes
oui mais en même temps on doit aussi
défendre une agriculture qui est
beaucoup plus orienté sur des produits
très segmenté à haute valeur ajoutée
secteur est on a besoin de l'une et de
l'autre de sa culture que l'une ou à
l'autre monde parce qu'ils ont tous deux
se disent que les plus gros veulent tuer
finalement les noms paysanne est
justement bien c'est pas notre accord il
sait pas l'intérêt mais bien sûr oui
regardez sur ce salon vous et d'autres
si oui tant d enfin ne jouons pas avec
les mots c'est trop sérieux
on a tout intérêt à défendre une aoc
comptez en corse ou dans le sud-ouest
comme on a aussi intérêt à mettre dans
des conditions économiques des
agriculteurs se sont même si je viens
deux secteurs qui n'ont vraiment plus
rien avoir en fait non son retour en
terre ils sont complètement ils sont
complémentaires même s'il s'éloigne de
plus en plus je voudrais quand même vous
donner un chiffre parce que moi je suis
irrité par tout ce que j'entends la
consommation en france est très
important la consommation en france de
produits sous signe de qualité bio label
aoc et indications géographiques
c'est moins de 20 % de notre
consommation qu'est-ce qu'on fait du
reste je pose la question qu'est ce
qu'on fait du reste
alors cessons d'opposer jouant les
synergies je vends les compliquer a
mérité mettons toutes ces agricultures
en bonne condition économique pour les
pouvant s'exercer encore une question
avant d'aborder la deuxième partie de
l'émission vous allez accueillir nicolas
sarkozy demain il sera accueilli comme
un tableau peine
mami lui a si ça me bloque les genoux
qui était pour l'heure nous sommes ici
sur un salon ouvert on accueille tout le
monde
ah ben voilà bien sûr mais là vous
m'avez dit tout à l'heure si madame le
maire non vous n'êtes pas allés
accueillir marine le pen quand vous irez
demain accueillir nicolas sion ne veut
pas passer sur le stand en effet ça
c'est son choix
non monsieur sarkozy passera sur les
allées lui demander des comptes parce
que parce que c'est facile d'accuser le
pouvoir en place mais par exemple la loi
lme dont on va parler tout de suite là
hein
depuis l'énorme le grenelle de
l'environnement crown est également oui
c'est dû à l'ancien président remonte à
son aile son quinquennat ça fait le
décompte savez bien sûr ah oui
d'ailleurs il se fâche souvent quand je
demandais compter dessus
oui alors il va se lâcher encore demain
c'est possible c'est aussi une
information vous allez vous fâcher
oui parce que encore une fois je crois
qu'il faut être équitable
bon il ya évidemment un certain nombre
de sujets qui sont affectés à d'autres
gouvernements et en particulier son
grenelle de l'environnement ce que les
paysans ont mal vécu c'est que
systématiquement depuis le grenelle
toutes les normes toutes les
réglementations ont été élaborés non pas
en concertation avec la profession
écoles mais contre la professeure à
l'école alors arrêtez ça c'est un monde
vous renvoyer dos à dos la gauche et la
droite
vous savez oui oui je suis je suis
paysan jeu indique ali je suis aux
dirigeants professionnels donc les
questions politiques de petite politique
ça ne m'interesse qui m'intéresse
en fait c'est ce qui se passe autour ne
virons voilà un ou deux ados la gauche
et la droite d'où le succès de marine le
pen aujourd'hui on ne vit pas en tout
cas de promesses c'est tout ce qu'on
peut retenir et aujourd'hui même si un
certain nombre de dirigeants de
l'opposition au beau jeu de critiquer ce
qui se passe
j'espère que dans leur programme ils
seront aussi intégrés y compris prendre
en compte peut-être des erreurs qu'il a
eu envers al quand vous aurez
recueillies sont eux mais on a géré
pendant quelques années verra quand vous
pourrez dépouiller tous les
questionnaires que jamais soumis lors de
ce salon cette année puisque vous avez
marre des visites apéritif et
dégustation a uniquement alors quelques
heures après la fin des négociations
commerciales avec la grande distribution
à ultimate hommes s'étaient c'était
cette nuit-là à minuit
y at il une victoire du pot de fer
contre le pot de terre c'est-à-dire d'un
des grands distributeurs qui étrangle
dit-on les petits producteurs vous allez
le dire dans un instant à anne chaon de
la sp et on écoute d'abord le ministre
de l'agriculture stéphane le foll pour
qui la course à la baisse des prix du
lait a été enrayée cette nuit en écoute
ce que je sais puisque c'est termine à
minuit c'est que pour ce qui est des
prix sur le lait des engagements qui
avait été demandé par le gouvernement à
la grande distribution aux industriels
de stopper ce qu'était la course à la
baisse au prix a été semble-t-il un
engagement qui étaient tenues on arrête
cette spirale à la baisse c'est la
demande qui a été faite ces généralités
sur des discussions d'après ce qu'on
avait eu comme information qui
continuait à mettre une pression sur les
prix
c'était insensé dans la situation à
calais voilà anne chaon est avec nous
notre concert de l'année
il a l'air sinistre
stéphane le foll vous partager son
soulagement
il semble même un peu optimiste
moi j'ai d'autres infos depuis minuit
hier soir puisque jusqu'à une heure du
matin on a essayé de savoir où en
étaient les négos comme on dit
je note qui a des contrats non signés à
minuit hier soir qui porte sur quoi
exactement
notamment sur la production porcine
qu'est ce qui bloque abbas qui bloque
c'est évidemment toujours cette tendance
naturelle ou depuis des années des
années toute négociation quel que soit
le contexte dans lequel nous soyons au
plan international ou européen démarre
avec des moins systématiquement c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous demandons nous
intégrer dans ses négociations
commerciales à travers notamment
peut-être une révision à nouveau de la
fameuse loi de modernisation de
l'économie on va en parler d indicateur
de coût de revient aux coûts de
production des producteurs agricoles
aujourd'hui faut bien voir comment ça se
passe la négociation elle se situe à
l'aval de la production agricole entre
une laiterie un industriel un abattoir
un transformateur et les enseignes de
distribution notamment sur l'aspect des
marques bon est-ce qu'à aucun moment on
prend en compte le coût de revient du
producteur jamais message récupérant là
c'est tellement aberrant et nous sommes
le seul secteur le seul aujourd'hui où
nous acceptons en france que nous
puissions vendre à perte
c'est le seul fait que l'industrie
agroalimentaire se plaint énormément
aussi le président de l'ania jean
philippe girard me disais ce matin c'est
encore pire qu'en 2015 pour
l'intimidation au bras un vieux
d'ailleurs c'est un petit clin d'oeil
que je vous fait il ya beaucoup de
journalistes d'investigation aujourd'hui
et j'en sais quelque chose
bon j'aimerais que de temps en temps
certains se faufile dans ces
négociations
ce serait très intéressant croyait venir
mettez nous sur la voir vous savez ce
que vous allez vivre
on va vous convoquez à 12h à 20h on va
vous faire passer mais entre temps vous
aura fait un temps dans une salle non
chauffée à peine éclairé sans rien à
discuter sans rien à déjeuner sans il a
dîné et c'est ça les négociations on
intimide les commerciaux on est
aujourd'hui dans un monde de barbare de
barbare de voyous dans les négociations
commerciales
je le dis avec beaucoup de force et ça
n'enlève rien ça n'enlève rien aux
propos que tiennent les directeurs ou
les patrons dans celle qui est noir is
oui je vais légales et les voyous on les
connaît alors c'est michel edouard
leclerc
c'est serge papin ces taux sont gérés
qui sont des voyous la main sur le coeur
il nous dit
aujourd'hui mais tout va bien on discute
on négocie sauf que leurs commerciaux
aujourd'hui je vais reprendre les propos
de l'un d'entre eux que je ne citerai
pas la grande distribution
c'est un bordel organisé voilà ce qu'on
me dit ça veut dire quoi
et aborder le créatif c'est à dire qu'en
gros on a des axes on a des orientations
et après messieurs les commerciaux
débrouillez vous vous êtes payés à la
commission
vous êtes bien fait votre boulot tant
mieux pour vous c'est la croissance
comme ça c'est la fameuse elle émeut la
loi dite de modernisation économique
adopté en 2008 qui a organisé en fait
700 pourrait entre autres
alors depuis il ya eu la loi monkey à
corriger quand même s'attendre le show
mais n'est pas allée assez loin et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je le dis avec
eux va beaucoup d'insistance si
désormais dans toutes les formes de
contrats de négociations nous
n'intégrons pas le maillon de la
production je pense qu'alors nous nous
retrouvons chaque année avec les mêmes
difficultés alors juste c'est une
avancée qui doit pouvoir être permise
par la loi
françois hollande s'est exprimé sur
cette question il menace effectivement
de durcir la législation
si cette liberté de négociation qui a
été accordée aux distributeurs au
prétexte de favoriser les consommateurs
se retourne contre les producteurs on
écoute chef de l'état cette loi avait
été votée dans le quinquennat précédent
c'est une loi qui a permis au
distributeur d'imposer ses règles
et bien maintenant dans ce que je
propose
on pourra faire afficher le prix
producteurs pour que le producteur
puisse être sûr que il ne va pas être la
variable d'ajustement entre l'industriel
et le distributeur et cette loi sera
votée avant l'été et je dois dire aux
distributeurs même si je ne veux pas
faire là aussi de simplification
outrancière qui dirait voilà les seuls
responsables ce sont eux faut aussi et
de voir qu'elle est
la responsabilité de tous mais je leur
dis attention à ce que vous allez faire
dans les 48 prochaines heures
parce que ça va déterminer le contenu de
la prochaine loi voilà pour cette
interview réalisée par olivier alleman
de notre de nos amis de deux campagnes
tv
si on revoit cette loi d'ici l'été comme
le propose le président et qu'on flèche
à chaque étape de la chaîne
le coût de revient on va peut-être lui
mais aussi l'industrie alors d'abord ce
seront des indicateurs à dire d'expert
c'est pas mon coût de revient qui va
être content vous pouvez bien le
comprendre mais en même temps par quels
moyens pouvons-nous quand même
définitivement introduire dans ces
négociations
et au fond par transparence avoir la
possibilité d'introduire quand même ce
coût de revient dans la négociation
c'est ça le sujet auquel nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui les éleveurs
parle de loi leclerc à propos de la lme
à l'époque vous aviez été associé aux
travaux
oui oui mais on n'a pas été entendu on
n'a pas été entendu pourquoi parce que
encore une fois il ya des intérêts
divergents et une des questions quand
même qui est posée aujourd'hui notamment
par rapport à cette guerre des prix à
laquelle se livrent les anciens qu'on le
veuille ou non c'est que nous ne sommes
plus aujourd'hui en face de plusieurs
enseignes
on est en face de quatre centrales de
désillusions pas puni quatre centrales
d'achat pardon qui aujourd'hui à
l'évidence bon pèse à peu près 25% du
marché
est-ce qu'on a capacité ou non à
réintroduire une sorte de pacte de
confiance entre producteurs
transformateurs et distributeurs
enseigne de restauration hors domicile
au passage également pour faire ensemble
qu'on retrouve quand même de l'équité
dans ces négociations alors elle tout à
l'heure vous demandiez à une action plus
vigoureuse des pouvoirs publics
vis-à-vis de l'europe mais c'est aussi
la demande qui est formulée dans
l'application de la loi lme par un
ancien ministre
un du quinquennat nicolas sarkozy c'est
hervé novelli qui était en charge on
s'en souvient de la consommation en
l'écouté vous pourrez réagir l'état a
failli l'état n'a pas poursuivi les
grandes enseignes comme moi je les fais
un certain nombre de ministres n'ont pas
agi comme il l'aurait dû parce que l'un
déséquilibre c'était la capacité
qu'avait l'état a signé les grandes
réseau de distribution
si les contrats n'était pas équilibrée
je les fais et je n'ai donc pas
le sens de recevoir sur la nécessité de
rechercher les encore montré les muscles
face aux distributeurs
je voudrais juste réagir je crois qu on
vous entend mais il ya un peu de bruit
autour de nous re pardonnez moi ce que
je voulais juste dire c'est que il ya
évidemment ce que la loi peut permettre
via ce que la loi doit faire notamment
en matière de contrôle mais nous avons
aussi chrome messieurs veulent un choix
qui est un problème de micro alors je
pense que je dois passer mon micro à
monsieur belin est ce que la loi peut
permettre il ya ce que la loi en
particulier doit métro notamment en
matière de contrôle de respect des
contrats c'est un point très important
mais il faut aussi en même temps que
dans nos filières dans la relation
contractuelle qui s'établit on est aussi
une capacité de jouer un peu plus sa
transparence
un peu plus sa confiance ok alors une
petite pause parce qu'il ya des
manifestants lara qui est qui qui qui
vous interpellent jeu le jeu le jeu les
criques j'ai cru le comprendre puisque
je vois des slogans contre les ogm on
vous entendu on vous entendu messieurs
la question sera posée à monsieur belin
qui effectivement a tenu des propos qui
n'ont pas dans votre sens sur ce sujet
mais on y reviendra alors la suite de
notre reversé sur rester sur la question
des prix il faut dire que là les
négociateurs de la distribution ils sont
bien aidés par l'effondrement des cours
mondiaux
oui quand on est sorti des quotas
l'année dernière au mois de mars
on n'a pas entendu le monde avait que
s'inquiéter de cette sortie de quotas ah
bon qui avait été négociée bien en avant
on était plutôt sûr on veut augmenter la
production on va miser sur l'exportation
sinon je suis comme paris non je suis
pas tout à fait d'accord et goose que je
reconnais c'est la france a été isolé
comment la discussion sur la sortie des
quotas nous étions nous demandeurs de
maintenir un système alors peut-être pas
de quotas mais de maîtrise de la
production
parce que nous craignons ce qui arrive
en ce moment faut bien voir que quand je
regarde sur un an à peine un an
d'ailleurs avril à décembre 2015
fin des quotas en avril des pays ont
augmenté leur production de cap à 10% et
pas des moins les pays-bas l'allemagne
l'irlande et c est pourquoi la france
n'arrive pas en ce cas là mais c'est pas
que la france ait riposté
non mais la france a une certaine idée
de la maîtrise de la production
on a progressé de 1% on est même en
dessous des autorisations de kotaku
n'était permise avant avril 2015
je pense que la france ne peut pas être
accusé aujourd'hui des tensions
production je vous donne un autre
paramètre intéressant
quinze ans en arrière la production de
porcs allemagne france espagne 25
millions de caution produit chaque année
en 2000 en 2015 15 ans après on est à 21
millions en france 40 en allemagne 46 en
espagne
donc cessons aussi de dire que la france
ne fait pas son travail
une certaine maîtrise une certaine
réussite de l'un la france est la
première puissance agricole voit que
dernières statistiques eurostat 18% à
elles seules 18 de la production
européenne
pourquoi est-ce que vous n'allez
donc le marasme et le malaise n'a lieu
qu ici pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas
l'impression que les paysans soient si
mal parce qu'en valeur relative
un certain nombre de nos collègues
aujourd'hui c'est vrai sur l'allemagne
mais c'est vrai aussi sur les pays
d'europe orientale centrale et orientale
c'est vrai pour l'espagne ont une
attitude beaucoup plus conquérant et
d'ailleurs viennent nous prendre des
parts de marché sur notre propre marché
alors il s'agit pas de dire il faut
produire plus il s'agit simplement de
dire est-ce que sur un marché européen
est ce qu'on peut se doter d'un certain
nombre et d'un minimum de moyens de
régulation de la production ou alors ça
veut dire qu'on organise à l'intérieur
même des frontières européennes
une espèce de concurrence exacerbée ou
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
les plus faibles tomberont je crois
qu'on n'a pas intérêt à ça aujourd'hui
concurrence avec les voisins immédiats
l'allemagne et l'espagne avec des
ouvriers payés à 3 euros de l'heure est
ce que quelque chose d'irréversible
on a assisté à la fin de la sidérurgie à
la fin de du textile en france
est ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui la fin de
l'élevage non bien sûr que non et
surtout pas parce que d'ailleurs ne
soyons pas paradoxaux contradictoire
quand le ministre a fait sa loi d'avenir
il a voulu mettre en avant justement
sinon un rééquilibrage en tout cas un
équilibre durable entre végétales et
animales
là dessus nous suivons mais encore
faut-il quand même que les productions
animales puisse aussi trouvé leur leur
propre comment dire leur propre
environnement économique pour pouvoir
perdurer je prends un seul exemple en
production laitière aujourd'hui
bien sûr on parle du grand wez mais je
vais prendre une autre région qu'est la
lorraine où le laisse de la france des
systèmes mixtes végétal animal sur la
même exploitation
si le prix du lait durablement ne permet
plus de rentabiliser le travail de
l'éleveur
que croyez-vous qu'il arrive ça voudra
dire qu on abandonnera l'élevage laitier
au profit de cultures céréalières c'est
pas souhaitable en termes d cliffs est
pas ce talent non plus en termes d'éco
système tout simplement vous parliez
vous même d'écosystèmes et de paysages
mais même au dax reste de d'équilibré
jettent à l'animal est ce que vous avez
des chiffres concernant justement les
conversions les éleveurs qui ont
abandonné l'élevage ou bien simplement
qu'ils se sont retirés qui ont jeté les
planches non j'ai pacheco facile mais on
en a tous les jours et c'est d'ailleurs
ce qui nous rend fébrile parce que
malheureusement là où il ya une densité
d'élevage
ça veut dire qu'on a les infrastructures
autour avec du ramassage de la collecte
des laiteries des ateliers de l'abattage
ou des coupes en porc ou en viande
bovine là dessus ça ça fonctionne là où
il ya une densité plus faible
imaginez que 10 15 % des éleveurs se
disent terminée moi je jeu mute sur un
autre système
est ce que ces entreprises de l'aval de
la production pourront perdurer
la réponse est non voilà il ya tout un
équilibre économique social and
ecosystem a résulté une dernière
question
une dernière question qui est toujours
avant d'aborder avec beaucoup de pudeur
des timidités même par le monde agricole
concernant les suicides des dernières
statistiques officielles dont on dispose
qui remonte à 2013 disait qu'entre 2008
et 2013 on avait un suicides
d'agriculteurs tous les deux jours
est-ce que vous avez des remontées du
terrain aujourd'hui pour vous dire où on
en est en particulier dans l'ouest où on
est confronté à la fois crise du lait et
du porc
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de pudeur
en parler parce que c'est un sujet
difficile et délicat les chiffres
aujourd'hui alors il faut les prendre
aussi expérience il ya parfois d'autres
causes que la seule pause économique
il yal isolement il peut y avoir des
points de familiaux fin mais tout ça se
cumulent un quelque part
et c'est vrai qu'on est plus proche
malheureusement d'un
d'un acte fatal pratiquement chaque jour
aujourd'hui en france pourrait
simplement dire que dans chaque
département maintenant nous avons des
cellules d'accompagnement des
agriculteurs en difficulté qui combine à
la fois des approches par des
travailleurs sociaux des psychologues
mais aussi un accompagnement social et
économie et je demande pour ma part puis
pas si on pourra loger sa dans cette
fameuse loi sapin 2 mais je demande
enfin nous ayons un vrai statut
d'agriculteur pour protéger ne serait ce
que le patrimoine personnel et privé de
l'agriculteur ce que lorsqu'il ya dépôt
de bilan et que malheureusement ça va
jusqu'à la liquidation
tout y passe nous sommes un des rares
secteurs à vivre cette situation
photo pro protège l'agriculteur et sa
famille l'outil de travail c'est l'outil
de travail
on peut avoir droit à l'échec on peut
avoir pour des tas de raisons exogènes
très souvent plus quand de jeunes la
possibilité aussi de déposer un bilan
d'agriculture merci anne chaon troisième
partie de l'émission donc vous allez
pouvoir répondre à vos détracteurs vous
alliez de l'ain il y en a dans
l'assistance on les a entendu un peu
bruyamment tout à l'heure j'ai vu des
panneaux dénonçant
les pesticides dont vous seriez donc un
tenant et puis également le recours aux
ogm c'est vrai que vous les défendez
d'une certaine manière mais les prises
de position se sont multipliés ces
derniers jours notamment depuis le début
du salon d'aviculture
alors donc la troisième partie est
simple un accusé qui avaient vu leur
répondais à vos critiques
que dites vous à vos détracteurs
nombreux par exemple jean luc mélenchon
et nicolas dupont aignan ce qui est en
impasse c'est tout ce modèle agricole et
les gens non ne peuvent pas se faire
entendre
vous avez vu le ministre de
l'agriculture lui il respecte les
traités européens
ce sont les traités européens qui ont
conduit à cette situation ensuite il est
flanqué de monsieur xavier beulin qu'est
le problème numéro un de l'agriculture
française à la tête de son syndicat
parce que ils représentent ce qui n'est
plus vraiment de la paysannerie
mais une espèce de haute industries
liées à la finance et aux grandes
transactions internationales dollars
c'est le pyromane qui vous fait semblant
d'être mon pied il a trahi les
agriculteurs il défend pas les quotas
laitiers défend pas un prix garanti
il est dans le conflit d'intérêt
permanent
dans le conflit d'intérêts il est plus
industrielles que paysans alors mais
quelle est la messe nous ont rejoints
sans michel consacré des voleurs qu'est
ce que vous répondez à nicolas dupont
aignan commentaire ça n'a fait aucun
commentaire
vous êtes interpellé au bois relancer
pas être interpellé ça c'est de
l'invectivé personnel pour se faire
plaisir sur un plateau devant un micro
ça n'appelle aucun commentaire aucune
réaction rails pour le jour le jour où
ces messieurs auront le courage
d'aborder les questions de fond je
viendrai débattent avec eux pas sur ces
sujets là parce qu il vous en faut du
courage vous pour répondre à toutes les
critiques à ce sont les journées et
comme sûr j'en ai je suis combatif mais
pas sur ce type de propos est-ce que je
vais m'occuper mois de la mine de
monsieur mélenchon ça ne m'intéresse pas
qu'ils viennent débattre des vrais
sujets
quand il nous dit aujourd'hui par
exemple on s'occupe pas des points de
l'agriculture on oublie les prix
garantis
on était content on était pour les les
quotas laitiers m'enfin où vont ils
chercher ces informations mais c'est du
populisme à l'état pur alors il ya une
personne qui a fait irruption sur le
plateau on vous invite madame bonjour
on vous donne la parole à une condition
c'est que vous acceptez quand même que
nous restions ici les maîtres du jeu
nous allons continuer notre émission
comme prévu avec monsieur blain nous
avons également nos questions à lui
poser vous savez elles ne sont pas tout
prendre
vous êtes intervenu avec des hauts cris
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de dire à
monsieur paulin qui est là et vous
répondra et puis vous retournerez dans
le public bien coûter on est venu dire
que nous on descend d une autre
agriculture qui qu'une agriculture qui
respecte le vivant je pense qu'on a
oublié que la terre c'était du vivant
que les agriculteurs sont des êtres
humains les animaux sont des êtres
humains que les semences c'est aussi de
la végétation vivante et que le
consommateur il a droit à mieux que le
système agricole actuel comme des fins
et que monsieur xavier beulin défense et
pas le nôtre
c'est un système qui va à sa perte qui
produit mâle qui détruisent nos
agriculteurs et vous même vous vous
rendez vous vous exprimez vos à quel
titre vous personnellement on en est
faux cheikh volontaire aujourd'hui on
est venu dénoncer les agrocarburants qui
nous ponctionne encore des terres et qui
cultive en porte des ogm cachés qui sont
faits vous résister à des pesticides qui
sont les ogm tournesol et colza minutes
et qui a été exclu de la réglementation
mais qui sont quand même les ogm ont
tant en terme scientifique du terme pas
bon maintenant vous êtes prête à écouter
la réponse de monsieur là je les écoute
volontiers il vous répond merci madame
voilà mes valeurs qu'est ce que je peux
répondre à madame d'abord je suis
d'accord avec elle que l'agriculteur sa
première fonction c'est travailler que
le vivant et la suite je suis
complètement en phase le vivant
pardonnez moi l'expression on en vit
tous les jours quand on est paysan
maintenant je veux rétablir 2,3 vérité
un aucune culture des ogm en france
aucune 2 nous consommons tous les jours
tous les jours en france et en europe
des ogm que l'on importe massivement ça
ne dérange personne en le séparant bercé
par enlever ça mais bien sûr on ne cesse
de le
leur local mais surtout les dombes micro
et que les surfaces est désormais là je
vous ai écoutés laissez-moi vous rêviez
l'essaimage aurait alors monsieur bell a
répondu oui
non mais allez madame conteste je peux
vous donner les chiffres 45 millions de
tonnes 35 de soja 10 de maïs et autres
productions banderoles dans l'union
européenne
ces ogm par exemple mais c'est une
vérité est ce que ça nous gêne
d'apporter ses productions troisième
réponse ne mélangeons pas tout les
sujets en matière d'innovation et en
particulier de technologie et je suis
navré de dire à cette dame que par
ailleurs je respecte je suis navré dû
dire qu'aujourd'hui une des réponses de
l'agriculture pour la france sera
évidemment l'innovation pourquoi parce
qu'on le voit bien tous les jours par la
semence par les technologies du
numérique par l'informatique embarquée
bref par un certain nombre de
technologies aujourd'hui par la
robotisation nous ferons de la culture
française à nouveau un pôle d'excellence
ne nous trompons pas de combat et je
voudrais enfin quatrième sujet dire à
cet homme
oui et je peux pas être pris en défaut
là dessus que la fnsea depuis toujours
défend toutes les agricultures c'est pas
une contre l'autre mais cessons
d'opposer ces agricultures
moi je suis très fier aujourd'hui quand
je vais dans tel et tel territoire de
pouvoir consommer des produits de
terroir et de dire ça c'est l'excellence
française mais je suis tout aussi fier
quand je vais à l'étranger et que je
trouve un certain nombre de produits qui
ont été exportés par les paysans
français qui font aussi notre fierté
n'opposons pas tout est art et culture
de grâce xavier beulin souhaite
interpeller un petit peu partout et même
applaudi de temps en temps la playbook
est ce que c'est pour vous le salon le
plus difficile que vous ayez eu à
connaître c'est pas pour moi la
difficulté à la dre personnel quand même
mais pas du tout la difficulté
aujourd'hui aller où j'avais prévenu le
président de république avant qu'ils
rendent dans le salon juillet les allées
sont très fraîches cette année je suis
pas trompé comme très froid pour ré
froide bon pourquoi parce que la crise
elle est profonde
durable aujourd'hui on peut pas dire un
agriculteur continue à faire de la
qualité on va te mettre des cahiers des
charges
on va te poser des réglementations le
prix a non sans n'en parle pas ça n'est
plus tenable sur le sens à la nation
c'est bien par vous attendez moi c'est
peu leurs problèmes nomel pointe de
bellaing il est pas là si demain mes
collègues de la fsu estime qu'ils sont
mal défendu change de président donc
c'est un faux problème
il ya zéro difficulté par rapport à ça
le congrès sera dans un an
malgré ça dans un match non est ce que
vous serez candidat remet témoin non la
question se pose pas pas encore non les
permettez-moi de rajouter un mot un seul
je suis accusée aussi aujourd'hui de
porter la responsabilité d'un groupe
agroalimentaire
je n'en suis pas le président exécutif
j'en suis le président au nom des
paysans qui sont majoritairement
actionnaires de ce groupe pourquoi parce
que ces mêmes paysans il ya trente ans
on fait un constat si on n'investit pas
sur la transformation sur la valeur
ajoutée de nos produits nous
n'existerons plus dans 30 ans là où je
suis mais vous êtes ce groupe
il fonctionne il permet à des tas de
filières d'avoir des débouchés oui il ya
aussi une partie de biochimie de
biocarburants et c'est ça qui vous est
alors j'ai mais qui m'est reproché au
nom de quoi
aujourd'hui tout le monde se gargarise
avec 21 on aura compris aujourd'hui tout
le monde se gargarise avec comme 21 en
parlant du renouvelable sur tous les
tons le renouvelable sais quoi dans
l'agriculture dans la forêt c'est de la
biomasse à disposition d'un certain
nombre d'utilisations voilà sur quoi
nous travaillons est alors y at il un
crime aujourd'hui il n'y a pas à
considérer selon vous mais il n'y a
aucun conflit d'intérêts défendre et
plus peu de moi j'aimerais chez moi ici
qu'à la place de cette dame il ya un
producteurs de colza ou tournesol qui
viennent dire grâce avril grâce à la
filière oléoprotéagineuse je vends mes
graines un peu mieux que le marché
mondial
et s'il était là il viendrait le dire
parce que voilà ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
alors voilà
j'ai vu la scène par nous ne sommes pas
des manifestants nous ne sommes pas des
peintures et encres collet est
absolument et on vous donne l'occasion
de défendre
ça va continuer parce qu'on va écouter
le porte parole de europe ecologie les
verts rabah décidément qui vous
critiquez vous répondez à l'est on
passera à autre chose
vous aviez blanc c'est une arnaque parce
qu'en fait c'est un grand industriel
cette l'agrobusiness 2 avril sofiprotéol
c'est pas du tout leurs représentants
des petits des petits éleveurs pas du
tout et même ses intérêts elles sont
opposés c'est à dire que quand nous les
écologistes ont dit on veut sauver
l'agriculture on veut sauver le paysan
dans la campagne qui est utile aux
territoires qui est nourri ses bêtes et
qui rend les élèves hors de la
maltraitance et sans pesticides et sans
ce que vous voulez
là on est dans le soutien à
l'agriculture durable quand vous avez
xavier beulin qui demande en gros des
baisses de cotisations pour pouvoir
développer toujours plus eh bien il
condamne à terme
l'agriculture française
un procureur alors qu'est ce qu'ils ont
envie d'avaler leur chance formidable
comment est ce que vous pouvez vous tous
les gens qui viennent s'exprimer et de
mélenchon à ce monsieur que je ne
connais pas parce que j'aime bien les
accusations mais enfin tu en entends
schirmeck certains d'entre eux viennent
me parler directement
plutôt que de parler par caméra
interposée que c'est vous lasser les
gens ils disent poids ils disent
aujourd'hui par icade on nous fermons
les frontières françaises faisons une
petite agriculture et tout ira bien
ils sont en train de condamner non pas
quelques centaines de milliers
d'agriculteurs ils sont en train de
condamner des millions d'emplois qui
c'est autour de ce plateau combien
génère d'emplois l'agriculture française
est hors agriculteurs nous avons un
million cinq cent mille dans l'accord
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est l'insee
bon est-ce qu'on veut détruire tout ça
oui il ya moins d'agriculteurs qui a 30
ans mais savez vous que depuis trente
ans la sphère agricole n'a pas perdu un
seul emploi il ya eu des transferts ya
moins à la production il ya beaucoup
plus en amont en aval et dans les
services rattachés à la culture c'est ça
la réalise que vous avez l'impression
parfois de faire un front un certain
obscurantisme des revenus du pro bien
sûr bien sûr oui oui ou alors ne
m'attendais de deux choses l'une soit
nous dit on
nous nions tout ce qui a été fait tout
ce qui a été signé comme accords
internationaux depuis 20 ou 30 ans à
l'om c'est les traite les européens et
dans ce cas là ok je suis la
démonstration ou alors nous prenons at
laz certain nombre d'orientations
politiques
je ne vois pas aujourd'hui y compris les
fissures en europe à remettre en cause
l'ensemble de ces dispositions
et dans ce cas là ça veut dire que je me
mesure demain un producteur néerlandais
un producteur polonais un producteur
allemand mais aussi un producteur
américain canadien argentin et c est ce
qu'on est capable d'accepter ça quelque
part
est-ce qu'il faut pas revoir aussi le
modèle de l'agriculture française on a
une division comme jamais du monde
agricole aujourd'hui avec cette crise
est ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
pouvez imaginer aujourd'hui revoir tout
cela tout remettre sur la table modifier
notre vision du monde avec toi louey il
n'y a pas de division du monde agricole
autant y aller jusqu'à les
manifestations à lorient mais qu'est ce
qu'ils expriment ces agriculteurs ils
expriment leur détresse leur colère leur
désarroi
ils pensent à leurs familles qui sont
derrière moi que je suis j'ai les larmes
quand un jeune vient me dire j'ai 30 ans
je tire pas de salaire j'ai deux enfants
c'est mon épouse parce que je les
envoyais travailler à l'extérieur qui
fait nourrir là qui fait mourir la la
marmite enfin est-ce qu'on peut accepter
ça c'est pas possible d'entendre ça donc
moi je me bats pour quoi pour qui la
dignité pour qui est vraiment une
dimension humaine et sociale derrière le
métier d'agriculteur mais ça se fera pas
comme sa part de l'incantation ça se
fera parce que derrière
oui on aura des filières solide oui on
aura des prix qui permettront de
rémunérer et oui surtout on reconnaîtra
enfin que dans cette chaîne alimentaire
le paysan c'est pas la variable
d'ajustement c'est par lui que devrait
commencer la construction des prix et
pas par lui que ça devrait finir on a
parlé des normes que vous combattrez un
peu plus de but de cette émission mais
elles font notamment inspiré par le
grenelle de l'environnement et le
principe de précaution ouais il s'impose
aussi dans les recherches
oui mais culturellement vous le
reconnaissez est ce qu'il est
il ya deux attitudes possibles chez
grossir oui ou bien on traite de la
confiance ou pas non mais où on traite
tout ça par la réglementation excessive
par la coercition par une sur
l'administration permanente où on traite
ça aussi par de l'innovation part de
leurs recherches par de vraies
alternatives
c'est que les paysans français maths le
français le matin se lève en se disant
tiens aujourd'hui je vais aller pondre
un peu des poux de phytosanitaires sur
mes parcelles
j'aime faire plaisir enfin on est tombé
sur la tête de nos comptes en sont les
premières victimes
c'est aujourd'hui ya en face ici animera
des tas d'innovations extrêmement
concret les drones tout ce qui va nous
permettre demain de faire des
interventions sectorielles sur nos
parcelles intervenir auprès de nos
animaux pour traiter le problème n'est
pas traité de manière préventive et
curative
tout ça c'est des progrès fantastiques
prenons tout ça en compte c'est comme ça
qu'on va gagner la partie
c'est pas en étant dans des postures
rétrograde de la culture si vous le
voulez bien sûr un peu peut-être plus
personnel
qu'est-ce qu'elle contacte vous gardez
vous aujourd'hui avec la terre vous avez
dit tout à l'heure vous étiez je suis
paysan cher monsieur vous êtes paysan
vous l'affiché où les gens
enfin si mais trois associés si mes
trois associés étaient là ils vous
diraient que le week-end je suis q sur
le tracteur ou chez au niveau des de la
traite ou des who delà du soin des
animaux
c'est ça mon boulot la semaine louis on
peut me reprocher d'être à paris d'être
à bruxelles d'état berlin dette
oui peut-être cela aujourd'hui que vos
détracteurs mettent sur la table en
disant que finalement les joueurs
castrais faudrait enlever une aussi mais
c'est tellement facile tout ça va ça ne
m'intéresse pas vraiment bon et puis la
vie d'un syndicaliste savez c'est très
éphémère 1 lorsque c'est usant et puis
ça c'est du matin que les nuits tous les
jouets vie parce que s'il ya des gens
qui vous crie un moment vraiment autre
chose ce qu'il ya peut-être aussi des
gens qui vous critiquent même en interne
elle a été meilleure et je pense qu'on
en entend des choses ici ou aller les
chercher témoigner faites-les témoigner
peut-être pas chez vraiment aussi pas
concernant devant une caméra ou façades
et alors on peut dire tout ce qu'on veut
la fse et c'est une organisation on ne
peut plus démocratique sa part de la
commune jusqu'à paris bon citez moi une
autre organisation qui soit aussi
démocratique
bon moi je suis représentatif des
paysans français qui monte lui le reste
c'est du verbiage c'est du fantasme
vous avez vous avez besoin vous pour
mieux vous comprendre peut-être est-ce
que vous êtes un syndicaliste plus
proche d'un pierre gattaz pour les
grands patrons plus proche de philippe
martinez pour la cgt vous vous situez où
au moins ça fait réagir au moins ça fait
réagir
vous vous situez ou alors la question
appelle une réponse on en exergue et
belin j'ai 57 ans je suis paysan dans le
loiret j'ai trois associés et je fais du
syndicaliste depuis l'âge de 22 et 23
ans et j'ai commencé mon métier à 17 ans
donc ceux qui rêvent ou ceux qui pensent
que bellaing c'est le type café chez pas
quoi qui a fait telle était la grande
écoute non je n'ai qu'un seul diplôme
selon permis de conduire et mon permis
moto auquel je suis très fier oui le
reste ça c'est votre loisir à côté de la
clôture
qu'on me traite j'ai au moins j'ai au
moins une fierté
j'ai au moins une pierre mais j'ai au
moins une fierté je n'en parle jamais et
puisque vous me poussée dans mes
retranchements je vais en parler pour la
première fois j'ai pris l'exploitation à
l'âge de 17 ans mon père décéda soir le
lendemain matin
juppé is an à 5 heures du matin j'arrête
et cours j'ai trois frères et soeurs
derrière moi gilbert et puis voilà les
choses se passent comme ça donc le reste
vous savez moi les donneurs de leçons et
l'est où ils sont et je ne veux pas
répondre à certaines attaques
je trouve cet affligeant je vais pas
savoir mais si monsieur mélenchon
monsieur dupont-aignan monsieur
tartempion ap tel et tel parcours pour
moi vous pouvez répondre aujourd'hui à
toutes et à tous les détracteurs
absolument c'est aussi pour cela qu'on
vous invite à vélo tendu merci
vous êtes venu avec nos supporters alors
là non non non
alors l'émotion et comment je me suis
cognée l'agriculture à à l'échéance de
50 ans pardon à l'échéance de 50 ans
comment est ce que vous voyez vous
comment est-ce que vous rêvez ce sera
notre dernière question comment est ce
que vous arrivez l'agriculture française
moi j'ai mal aux tripes quand je vois la
rupture française qui régresse j'ai mal
aux tripes
on a un potentiel formidable dans ce
pays le premier d'entre eux c'est le
potentiel humain fantastique un savoir
faire exceptionnel des produits
d'excellence une diversité agricole un
climat des terres on a tout ce qu'il
faut
comment se fait-il comment ce fait-il
comment se fait-il qu'aujourd'hui on ne
soit pas en capacité d'assumer d'
assumer politiquement socialement
sociologiquement un pôle agricole un
pôle alimentaire qui devrait
indique-t-on dans ce pays
parler d'agriculture aujourd'hui c'est
la maladie honteuse enfin quand même
est-ce qu'on peut un peu se reprendre et
se dire enfin on est capable de se
promouvoir non seulement promouvoir mais
d'accompagner cette promotion avec
quelques mesures clés redonner confiance
permettent l'investissement permettent
l'innovation rayonner sur les marchés
satisfait en aux consommateurs
c'est ça notre projet moi j'en ai pas
d'autre le reste ne m'intéresse pas
l'intérêt général avant tout mon intérêt
personnel vous savez à l'âge où j'ai il
est derrière moi donc c'est fini
merci
merci merci xavier collin d'avoir
répondu à toutes ses questions lors de
cette émission
même les questions qui fâchent certains
mais vous y avez répondu avec beaucoup
de courage et détermination merci à vous
et à très bientôt